you know so
i'm just talking there you go mic check
check check one two three four
five four three two one it's remote only
jim mult only
we'll go to the handheld mic you're
ready
jeff jackson
um
yes
hello
that's right
oh
goodbye
yes
oh man
good night
thank you
oh i can get over it
uh
hey how are you i'm well
so i'm in the briefing room
uh
no you guys are
all right
this time last year yeah
what
thank you
that was the first day there so yeah so
we were there yeah
i thought you were gonna get tossed
oh
i mean i thought the trip might get
canceled we just like
we just came in under the wires
it was just a week later i think
everything um like two weeks later they
shut everything down yeah
i was i was sitting in the i don't know
here like yeah
okay my friend was here from london
we sat we're sitting at the bar i think
yeah unless
right but you know we he's like you guys
could stay down and he was kind of
freaking out
the owner he gave us inspiration
and then they they they freaked out
because they thought they'd get stuck
here so they
uh they managed to get a ticket to get
out as soon as possible
okay
uh
matt leitch
is yeah
it's his birthday
you probably
attitude
foreign
every day
oh
um
thank you
is
and then
drivers
um
around
is
two minute warning on the press briefing
two minute warning on the press briefing
thank you
so
i'm in the middle of there
thank you thank you so much
i think you're right
am i supposed
where's
all right
oh i will tell you masks are a little
tricky with earrings on so just bear
with me here
okay um let's have a couple of items at
the top
okay learned my lesson on earrings all
right um
today the president will deliver remarks
to mark the 50
uh mark 50 million shots that have been
administered
since he entered office in his remarks
he will provide an
update on the strong progress we've made
across our pandemic response to date
he will commend the covert response
team's extraordinary whole of government
effort
to get shots in the arms of americans as
well as the work of so many americans
who have stepped up to the plate in this
moment
he will also remind americans that now
is not the time to let our guards down
especially in the face of new variants
he will continue
he will encourage people to continue
wearing a mask and get vaccinated
when it is their turn i also have some
brief updates on the winter storm that
affected a few states
last week as many of you saw last night
the president approved the state of
oklahoma's major disaster declaration
request
this action will authorize fema to
provide both public and individual
assistance
including grants for temporary housing
and home repairs
low-cost loans to cover uninsured
property losses
and other programs to help individuals
and business owners recover from the
effects of the disaster
power and water restoration continue
across texas louisiana and oklahoma
accelerated vaccine shipments are
occurring and vaccination appointments
are being rescheduled
and expanded to accommodate those
canceled last week
and as you all know the president is of
course traveling to texas
tomorrow today the vice president also
visited a
local giant pharmacy in washington dc
that is participating in the amer
administration's federal retail pharmacy
program the program is increasing access
to coven 19 vaccines across the country
the biden harris administration is
committed to ensuring americans have
access to vaccine in their own
communities including
at local pharmacies and last week alone
the administration doubled
our allocation to pharmacies to over 2
million doses across 7 000
pharmacies with that darlene why don't
you kick it off
great i have a question to start off
with about neurotendon
um so when she tweeted that quote a
vampire has more heart than
ted cruz when she compared senator
mcconnell to voldemort
and when she called senator collins
quote the worst
those comments meet the president's
standard of treating everyone with
dignity and respect
well first i'll note that when nira
tandon testified
just a few weeks ago she apologized for
her past comments
and that she would be joining an
administration where as we've noted in
here
there's an expectation of a high bar of
civility
and engagement whether that's on social
media or in person and we certainly
expect
she would meet that bar did the
president and the transition team
underestimate how much of a problem her
tweets would become
the president nominated nira tandon
because she is qualified
because she's experienced because she
has a record of working with people who
agree with her and disagree with her
uh with and she has decades of
experience and plus she has lived
experience
of her own having benefited from a
number of the programs that she would
oversee
as a daughter of a single parent and
somebody who
benefited from food stamps at certain
points in time she would bring a new
perspective
to the role that's why he nominated her
to the job and why we're continuing to
fight
uh for her confirmation on the 50
million
shot this afternoon does the white house
is the white house able to say
where and when that shot was
administered what state
even some characteristics about who may
have received it yeah
it's a great question i think the
challenge is that we get data in from so
many different sources on a daily basis
from states from pharmacies
from mass vaccination sites that we um
we hit that point the hit the 50
millionth shot
uh sometime yesterday if not a little
bit before but we can't fine-tune
exactly the person
uh who hit that point hit that shot
thank you
sure go ahead any update on the
president's phone call or
scheduled phone call with king salman
saudi arabia i don't have an update
as i noted yesterday as soon as that
call happens we expect it to be very
soon
we will of course provide a readout to
all of you you said when they do talk
that the president
won't hold back will he be following up
this talk with actions are sanctions on
the table
i think there are a range of actions uh
that are on the table but
uh the first step is uh the next step i
should say is for the president to speak
with the king we expect that to happen
very soon
as you know we've committed to the
release of an unclassified report that
would come out from
uh dni and not from the white house uh
and
of course our administration is focused
on recalibrating the relationship as
we've talked about in here previously
and certainly there are areas where we
will express
concerns and leave open the option of
accountability there are also areas
where we will continue to work with
saudi arabia
given the threats they face in the
region what's the hold up to the phone
call
is the king avoiding your calls i i
don't think that's the characterization
the president has a busy schedule
the king obviously uh i can't speak to
his schedule i'm not his spokesperson
but
we expect the call to happen very soon i
think there was some inaccurate
reporting about it being confirmed when
it wasn't a confirmed call yet
and you have made clear that the
president's going to be speaking with
his counterpart with the king not with
the crown prince
but given the crown prince's role in the
future of the kingdom and that he is
expected to be implicated here
why not speak to the person expected to
be responsible
well i think the president's
conversation will cover a range of
topics with the king there's obviously
a lot to discuss with uh saudi arabia
and with the leaders of saudi arabia and
as i noted i've previously noted the the
crown prince has
been engaged with his appropriate
counterparts the president will be
engaged with his appropriate
counterparts and we're engaged at many
levels
uh with leaders in saudi arabia so will
the conference's counterparts hear
what austin he's teaching him about this
issue though he spoke with him
last week they did a readout i don't
think i have anything more about uh
their call
to read out go ahead all right thank you
i just want to ask what the post office
a couple of questions you said earlier
today that there was
concerns against the leadership but it's
clear that the leadership can do better
and so that's our hope
you clarify whether you want to change
in the post-message general now that
you've named
new members to the board secondly
they've announced the purchase of the
new fleet
the president of course announced on
january 27th
to study uh pursued aiming at
electrifying the government's fleet
including the post office
uh only ten percent of the fleet given
out their line will be elected
if you plan to change that order or
changes to it at all
sure uh the second question i'll have to
follow up on more specifics on it that
is certainly something the president's
committed to
i don't have an update on it but i can
venture to get one for you
on the first question um some people may
not be following this as closely as you
and i have so let me just give a little
more context
of course the president's committed to
the post office the postal service's
success
uh which is why yesterday he nominated
three extremely qualified individuals
to fill the empty spots on the board of
governors uh anton
hajjar amber mcreynolds and ron strowman
and the american people uh highly value
the postal service and the men and women
who deliver our
mail every day and we're working hard to
do exactly that but i think we can all
agree
most americans would agree that the
postal service needs leadership that can
and will do a better job
now as you know uh and but not everybody
knows
uh it's up to the board of uh governors
uh of which we just nominated
three individuals to serve to determine
the future of leadership there and we
certainly leave it up to their
discretion sounds like you're signaling
that the board
could take a look at it does the
president have confidence
i think the president is certainly
familiar with the process he believes
the leadership can do better and
uh we're eager to have the board of
governors in place
a slightly separate subject you may have
seen that gamestop is spiking
again as our similar stocks or stocks
there i call them
do you have views on whether the fcc or
the administration the treasury
secretary will weigh in
if we continue to see these sort of mean
stops fluctuating and spiking like this
well as you know um the sec had uh had
been
uh had had overs has oversight i should
say and certainly has been
watching it closely monitoring closely
the treasury secretary also convened a
meeting
just a few weeks ago but i would
certainly send you to them on what their
plans are for
monitoring engagement or speaking to it
i would send you directly to them to
give any update on
their progress and how they're
monitoring it sure go ahead
uh the president is going to texas
tomorrow he's obviously going to show
empathy for the
victims of the storm does he have a
message for the leadership
in texas on how to better prepare um for
winter storms and
what can the federal government do to
kind of coerce private industry
there to better prepare well let me
first say
that he'll be traveling for the most of
the day with the governor
um and he'll be they'll be surveying the
damage uh
and i'm sure he'll be getting an update
and briefings from him directly
president doesn't view the crisis and
the millions of people have been
impacted by it as a
democratic or republican issue he views
it as an issue where he's eager to
get relief to tap into all the resources
in the federal government to make sure
the people of texas
know we're thinking about them we're
fighting for them and
we're going to continue working on this
as they're recovering there's plenty of
time
to have a policy discussion about uh
better weatherization better
preparations and i'm sure
that's one that will be had but right
now we're focused on getting relief to
the people in the state
uh getting updated briefings tapping
into all of the levers of federal
government
there's a lot of hearings uh on the hill
about how the capitol police responded
or
prior to the january six events um
mike pence and his family were there
that day
secret service had intelligence
briefings presumably
is there any concern or review about how
the secret service
assessed intelligent briefings and
whether there was any missteps on their
part
uh reviewed by the
mike pence and his family were at
capitol hill that day um clearly there
was
intelligence out there that suggested
things could happen
and curious to whether there's been any
any review by the secret service or
ordered uh about the secret service
accident that day
and they're how they handle it i i'd
encourage you to reach out to the
leadership of the secret service uh to
get a further comment on it
um go ahead kristen i'll come to you
thank you jim
a little bit of housekeeping on the
texas questions if i could
will president biden invite senator cruz
and
cornyn to texas with him to travel in
air force one
well dr biden is traveling of course
with
us to uh to texas with the president of
texas there are some limitations on
space available so there are not members
i don't believe i will double check on
this
of any party traveling with the
president um to texas
uh but again he's going to be spending
the day traveling with governor abbott
and surveying the damage on the ground
will they be
a part of his uh plans to survey the
damage
will they join him in any of those
events tomorrow has there been any
invitation
uh i'm happy to follow up on it uh for
you kristin but i'm not aware of their
plans to participate in the events
tomorrow but i can check
okay i want to ask you about the uptick
in migrants at the border
some members of the democratic party are
displeased
with the way the administration is
handling children who are being held at
the border alexander ocasio-cortez
tweeted this quote this is not okay
never has been okay
never will be okay no matter the
administration or
party is this a failure on the part of
this administration
well first i can't speak to what this is
that is being referred to
in these detention facilities well
that's not what's happening uh
and you know we will be doing some
briefings of course with members of
congress but what is happening now is
there are
children uh fleeing prosecution
fleeing uh threats in their own
countries
traveling on their own unaccompanied to
the border
and our focus is on approaching this
from the view of humanity
and from and with safety in mind and so
the steps that we have taken is
uh they are uh of course processed as
quickly as possible
ideally with a maximum of three days
through cbp
then they are transferred to facilities
overseen by hhs
we had to open reopen a new facility uh
that had previously been closed because
of covid protocols
because previously because we can't have
kids in beds next to each other we need
space appropriate it's been revamped
there are there's educational services
there there are uh
their health services and medical
services but our objective is to move
them as quickly as we can
to families that have been vetted and to
of course reunite kids with their
who says families sees these images and
it's not okay from her perspective
well look uh we will work of course with
congresswoman ocasio-cortez on a range
of issues and we look forward to doing
that what i'm
conveying from here is what the actual
circumstances on the ground
and the tough choice that we have had to
make there are only a couple of options
here so
either we send kids back to a very
dangerous journey
back to their countries that's not a
good option i don't think anyone would
support that option
we send them to families that have not
been vetted we've seen challenges with
that in the past where kids have then
been trafficked
that is not a good option in our view
our best option in our view
is to get these kids processed through
hhs facilities
where there are covid protocols in place
where they are safe where they
can have access to educational and
medical care there are no there are very
few good options here and we chose the
one we thought was best
i just want to ask you about cpac i know
you got some questions about this
yesterday if i could try again
based on our reporting former president
trump is going to be talking about
president biden's immigration
policies he will point to the uptick in
migrants
coming to the u.s how is the
administration planning
well we're not looking to former
president trump or any of his advisors
as a model for how we're approaching
immigration
in fact we're in the circumstance we're
in because uh
not only was their approach inhumane it
was ineffective
and so we're going to forge our own path
forward uh we'll see
what he says but our focus is certainly
not what on president trump is saying at
cpac
go ahead thank you jan uh the head of
the group the president is going to meet
with today
the national governors association
andrew cuomo
is being accused of sexual harassment by
a former staffer named
lindsey boylan she says that cuomo while
he was governor
gave her an unwanted kiss on the lips he
asked her to play
strict poker is the white house worried
about this becoming a distraction from
an important meeting about toby response
well let me first say that the president
has been consistent in his position
when a person comes forward they deserve
to be treated with dignity
and respect their voice should be heard
not silenced and any allegations should
be reviewed
governor cuomo is also the governor of
one of the largest states in the country
that has been one of the hardest hit
with millions of people still suffering
from an ongoing pandemic and an economic
crisis
and our focus is to continue working
with governors from across the country
from a range of states on how we're
helping people in their states he also
is still head of the national governors
association hence he's
at the event today and to him being in
charge of the governors and
in charge of such a big state will the
president
uh talk to him about these accusations
from democrats in
the new york legislature that cuomo
misled the public
about deaths in nursing homes throughout
pandemic
well this is a meeting and a
conversation with a range of governors
about how we can all
work together to address the pandemic
and get relief to the american people
and that's what i expect the focus of
the meeting to be on
there are some democrats in new york who
want a but who want congressional
hearings about these debts in nursing
homes there was a
formal aide who told lawmakers in
february
that the cuomo administration withheld
the number of residents who died in
hospitals
from the public due to the fear that it
would be used against them by federal
prosecutors
is this something the white house thinks
would be appropriate for
a congressional hearing it's it's really
up to congress to determine uh how they
want to
review or have hearings uh on those
reports
and i know you asked about this this
weekend but i'll try again
uh does president and still thank andrew
cuomo
it's the gold standard for copen
leadership and that he's doing a hell of
a job
which he has said about
well first of all i think to be fair
let's put all the
comments in context which sometimes is a
missing from these conversations we have
in here or during interviews
at the time which was i believe april of
last year
the president spoke out and said
positive things
about a range of governors democrats and
republicans who were stepping in when
there was a vacuum of leadership
at the federal level when they were
getting no information when they were
getting no help and no guidance
from the former trump administration he
had he made some positive comments about
governor cuomo and his role in new york
at the time as he did about a range of
governors okay and then one more on
climate change
there's been some reports about meeting
with airline ceos
next week how important is it to the
white house to reduce airline
emissions as part of an overall climate
agenda
i'm not actually familiar with that
meeting do you know who is with uh
gino mccarthy and some of the airline
companies ceos
i'd have to look back into it i don't
have any more details on that meeting
i'm happy to uh go ahead thank you just
want to follow up on the accompanying
children uh is present open to creation
and ombudsman within the health and
human services department
this has been proposed by congressional
progressive caucus chair
familia ajaya paul this person would be
able to go in
uh and check out the facility to see the
care that that the children are
receiving report back to congress
uh with the administration's support
such a role within health and human
services
i i have actually not spoken with
president about that proposal
by congresswoman ryan paul uh we have i
should note i think
uh someone asked us the other day we
have had cameras
hhs has had cameras in there also to uh
make sure people in the public the media
are able to see
um the conditions in these facilities
and we'd certainly be open to supporting
that in the future but
i'd have to follow up with him and our
legislative team on that proposal those
lawmakers obviously being able to go in
and see the care of the children we
would certainly
support that sure one more question in
2018 it was discovered migrant children
being forced to take psychiatric
medication without knowing the drugs
they were taking things like lithium and
so on
what's being done obviously these
children need psychiatric care some
cases have been traumatized
they've had a difficult time what can
uh the administration do to assure if
these kind while the children are
getting the care they need
there would be no such abuses well i
would say first um we are not
using uh the past management as our
guide
and uh the we have uh the secretary of
homeland security is of course
overseeing uh in coordination with the
health and human uh health and homeless
sorry hhs secretary it's a mouthful
um to ensure that these children are
treated humanely
uh they are provided with the medical
assistance they need
the mental health assistance they need
and you're absolutely right i mean these
kids have been through
a trauma and we want to treat them
humanely
and make sure they're kept safe uh so i
would send you of course to the uh
hhs team to get more specifics of how
it's monitored but
certainly that's our expectation go
ahead in the back so
um has the president been following um
brexit and has it uh
gone as he expected so far um
and does he share the position that
president obama expressed in 2016 when
he said
brexit would put the uk at the back of
the queue for a trade deal for the us
well lots happened on brexit and in the
world since 2016 i think it's fair to
say
uh i will say that uh president biden is
focused on
strengthening our domestic economy
through significant investments in
american workers and competitiveness
that's his focus he's committed to
prioritizing those investments at home
before signing new trade deals
that's his approach and that's how he
sees
trade deals in general around the world
uh making those investments is critical
to restoring the middle class and making
us more competitive so
our team is still reviewing negotiations
that were begun under the prior
administration
uh ambassador designate tai of course
had her hearing
uh this morning and she will be
essential to that review
has the president spoken to any uh
leaders from africa
yet and how concerned is he about uh
competition from china
in africa well certainly we've long
been concerned the united states has
long been concerned about competition
from china and africa
we we provide readouts whenever he does
calls with foreign leaders uh so he has
not quite made it
uh to every foreign leader at this point
in time um but i'm sure that um
engagement with china and uh the bar and
the uh
we expect to be set um would be part of
those disc many of those discussions
go ahead uh senate budget committee
chairman bernie sanders said this week
that he's hoping to use
reconciliation to pass the president's
infrastructure package
is the president open the other approach
and has he spoken with bernie sanders
about it
that would require having an
infrastructure package right to decide
how it would pass
well let me first say that our focus is
on the american rescue plan
uh and of course the president has
talked about what his buildback
better agenda would look like on the
campaign trail infrastructure is a part
of it he's been a long fan of investing
in infrastructure
long outdated long overdue i should say
but he also wants to
do more on caregiving help our
manufacturing sector do more to
strengthen access to affordable health
care
so the the size the package the
components of it the order
that has not yet been determined and i
feel like that's the next step
i don't expect the president or any of
us will preview anything until we have
the american rescue plan through
one more uh the chief of staff said
yesterday that the
president wouldn't overrule the
parliamentarian if she decides
that you can't raise the minimum wage as
part of this broader economic relief
package
if that is the decision what's the next
step on raising the minimum wage does he
expect to
introduce a stand-alone bill would be
part of his upcoming economic
broader well first let me say it would
be a serious step for the vice president
to take that step and obviously she and
the president respect the
uh historic institution of the senate it
would also require 50 votes
uh so it's not just a stand-alone step
that
any vice president could take uh in
terms of the minimum wage
you know we're still waiting uh for the
uh conclusion
of the uh parliamentarians um uh
uh view on whether or not the raise and
the minimum wage
should be included can be included i
should say in the american rescue plan
uh that's where the state the step the
process is at this stage
in time the president included an
increase in the minimum wage because he
believes it should be
um it's a long overdue and american
workers should not be
uh struggling to make ends meet but
that's the next step
and and we'll have to go from there
is the administration considering easing
social distancing rules from
a company minors in these detention
facilities to allow more
unaccompanied minors to to be
i'm not aware of that consideration i
mean one of the reasons that we opened
this facility revamped this facility
is because we did not want to put
unaccompanied minors
at risk and we obviously follow cdc
guidelines which is six feet of
separation
so uh my expectation is we would
continue to follow those guidelines
um go ahead so march 21st is coming up
as the first anniversary of border
restrictions between the u.s
and canada and mexico um back in october
republicans and democrats in texas
demanded
that the trump administration release a
factory opening
um these restrictions have obviously
divided families they've devastated the
economy on the border
um does the can we expect a plan from
the vitamin administration anytime soon
on
um potential quarterly openings and what
would the parameters
i do expect there will be more on this
soon
it would likely come from the state
department um so i would send you to
them for an update on the status and the
timeline
go ahead thank you very much jen um i
wanted to ask about the
domestic terrorism review the president
asked for a 100-day domestic terrorism
review he had the
dni take charge of that and worked
closely with the fbi
and dhs what does the president expect
to come out of that review at the end of
100 days if you want to see a report
a list of recommendations what is he
expecting to see
what would we expect to see out of that
review well we have more than 60 days
left until we hit 100 days
um in terms of the format of what the
review will look like
i would expect some form of a report i
don't know yet if it will include
specific recommendations or if it will
then launch a policy process
i can talk to our team and see if
there's more specifics the president
been briefed and updated on the progress
of that review we're about 33 35 days
into it
as you know the president has daily
meetings uh
as a part of the pdb and certainly
tracking threats to our homeland is a
part of what's discussed there but
i don't have any update for you on
updates on the overall report that's not
due for more than 60 days
and what's the president's assessment
now of the threat from domestic
terrorism
um you know we obviously saw uh domestic
terrorists involved in groups of armed
groups involved in
the january sixth insurrection uh in the
subsequent weeks um how has that changed
well the reason that he asked his
national security team to do a
comprehensive review was so that he
wasn't
looking at it and we weren't looking at
it through the prism of
one event versus another event or
through a political lens
so i'm not going to be able to offer for
you a day by day or week by week
assessment
we're going to wait for this review to
conclude and then we'll use that
as guidelines for our process and our
policies moving forward
go ahead george thanks man i have a
question for myself
and then one for uh reporters who can't
be here
on the budget new presidents put their
own stamp on on the budget and all
recent new presidents have given a
speech in february
that talks about the budget and then
within a month or so
submitted uh their revisions uh
can you talk about what your the
president's timetable is
and given and how much it's affected by
the fact that
the pandemic the less than cooperative
transition
and the failure to confirm a director
sure george well the president is
certainly looking forward to
sharing his budget priorities for the
fiscal year with congress and of course
the american people
as our nation faces unprecedented
challenges we anticipated
during the transition and we talked
about it a bit during the transition
that the budget would be the transitions
we encountered uh
from political appointees at omb during
the transition
those roadblocks definitely delayed the
process
uh we have a strong place in team in
place of course at omb
uh many of many of whom are career
officials who are working through
administrations to put budgets together
but the lack of a confirmed head of omb
certainly doesn't help to expedite
the process so we certainly anticipate
it will be delayed i don't have an exact
timeline on it but
i wouldn't expect a budget rollout or
announcement in february
do you think it would be possible to
give that kind of traditional speech or
does a pandemic make that impossible
a traditional budget speech congress
well i i think we would be looking at a
non-traditional approach to a joint
session i don't have any update
uh on what that will look like at this
point simply because i don't think
anyone could envision
500 members of congress in there with a
president of the united states during a
pandemic but i don't have any updates on
the timeline or format
one from other reporters is sort of a
follow-up to your
earlier answer when you do
make the declassify the report on saudis
will that come at the same time as you
announce
any kind of sanctions or actions or is
that a separate timetable for those two
i'm not going to be in a position to
preview that i would just say the
unclassified report would be released
from dni not from the white house
um and i would just broadly remind you
that
uh oftentimes any actions uh related to
global
issues or uh don't come out of the white
house they come out of a range of
agencies
uh but i don't have anything to preview
for you at this point in time
uh go ahead thank you um i would like to
ask you about
uh india and pakistan today announced
ceasefire along the shared border
including land of control these were the
first i think after 2003 that they have
it on this
well the united states welcomes the
joint statement between india and
pakistan that the two countries have
agreed to maintain
strict observance of a ceasefire along
the line of control
starting on february 25th this is a
positive step towards greater peace and
stability in south asia
which is in all shared are is in our
shared interests and we encourage both
countries
to keep building upon this
enough in the fight progress terrorism
okay sorry
i'm sorry the masks always make it hard
to hear people on the way back can you
say that one more time
is pakistan doing enough in the fight
against terrorism
well of course we remain um closely
engaged with a range of leaders and
officials in the region including those
in pakistan
but in terms of an assessment of that i
would point you to the state department
or the intelligence department
president issued a proclamation in which
he revoked the
his predecessor's policy on green issues
of new green cards to those people who
are outside the country
there are a lot of legal immigrants who
leave the country and they want to make
this country as their home
but they're having a decade-long wait
for the issue of green card so that
once they get it the potential is
unfolded they can
open their company they can have the
startups
and they give employment great
employment degree development this
country
what's the present message to those
legal immigrants in this country
well the president believes that it's
important
and long overdue to put in place uh
immigration
to modernize our immigration system and
that includes
taking steps to help ensure that
high-skilled workers
can stay in the country and can go
through the proper process to stay in
the country
so we're eager to work with democrats
and republicans in congress to get that
done
one more time several republicans on the
hill and including
nikki haley the former u.s ambassador
are
urging president biden to uh
not to participate in next week's
chinese winter olympics
has the president taking a decision on
that uh there hasn't been a final
decision made on that and of course we
would uh
look for guidance from the u.s olympic
committee
go ahead thank you jen back on
immigration do you believe that you have
a crisis at the border and
is the government now acting as if you
had a crisis at the border
well certainly um you know having uh
unaccompanied minors uh travel across
the border and
so many that we are looking we had to
open a new facilities
is something that we uh take incredibly
seriously
and we um you know are eager to of
course address humanely
uh and uh with the focus of keeping them
safe i don't think i'm gonna put new
labels
on it from here or from the podium but
it is a
a priority of the administration it's a
priority of our
secretary of homeland security and
certainly of the presidents who's kept
abreast of the developments
reunification the lawyers the pro bono
lawyers that have been working
with the families and trying to get them
together announced yesterday that about
100 families have been reunited
from those 600 kids that were in the
system and lost
has the government been working with
those pro bono lawyers as well to
to get that process going well this
program is being overseen the family
reunification task force by the
department of homeland security by our
secretary of homeland security
uh of course he will be doing an
official uh report
at about the 120 day mark but i would
send you to them for any updates or
status of our work with those lawyers
texas ruling about the 100-day
moratorium on deportation
will the government appeal to a higher
court will that legal process continue
well uh let me first
say a couple of things about this
because we haven't talked about this in
the last couple of days
the pause of on deportations uh was a
time to reset our enforcement priorities
so that we focus on threats to national
security and public safety as opposed to
mothers and fathers
who are long-standing members of our
community who are in many cases
performing essential work during the
pandemic
so the department of homeland security
has put in place interim enforcement
priorities and is reviewing the prior
administration's
policies and practices the court's
ruling still allows us to do this
in terms of next steps uh or how we will
approach it from here i would send you
to our
department of justice and address
immigration at all down in texas
tomorrow
the president will be um uh certainly
speaking uh
uh you know about uh kovid and
addressing the pandemic
uh he will also be speaking about the um
impact of the storm on the people of the
state
and i know immigration is an issue on
the minds of
many people there but i don't have
anything to preview in terms of whether
he'll address it while he's there
go ahead this afternoon
the president has made equity a key part
of his response
mixed results on that some states have
no data for instance on race
the people vaccinated other states the
data is showing that
white and asian people are getting the
vaccine disproportionately as compared
to black and latino people
does the president think enough is being
done with regards to equitably
distributing the vaccine
the president has always known from the
day he
took office and as has the vice
president that uh
addressing uh ensuring that we equitably
equitably distribute the vaccine would
be a big challenge
because there was a lack of uh accurate
data
as you referenced because it is uh
challenging you have to use a number of
approaches to get into communities where
there is vaccine hesitancy which is an
ongoing issue that we're working to
address
so of course he feels that there is more
that needs to be done
and that there's more of that across his
team he will continue to
encourage people to take action on
now there are a number of steps um
including um
partnering with community and
faith-based organizations enhancing
public transit options
working of course distributing vaccines
to pharmacies
opening mass vaccination sites that we
are taking as an administration to more
equitably
distribute the vaccine but there's more
work to be done and we expect
as we get to the point where there are
enough vaccines for americans uh
300 million by the time we're get to the
end of july or if not sooner
uh that one of the challenges will be um
you know ensuring it's equitably
distributed
and that people who are uh have a
history of vaccine hesitancy take the
vaccine
go ahead there are reports that if
congress launches a 911 style
commission to investigate the january
6th insurrection
nancy pelosi would want it to have seven
democrats
and four republicans as part of the
makeup
would the white house be satisfied with
that or would you rather see it more
evenly
uh distributed by party we leave that up
to
congress uh leaders in congress uh to
determine what that uh will look like
and on immigration why does the white
house think
there is this surge of unaccompanied
children
right now your critics are saying it's
because you're not sending anybody
back any of these unaccompanied children
back do you share that
well i think there's a couple reasons
one there's conditions that are in these
countries that
uh we have not done enough to help
improve and that's why there is funding
in the president's immigration bill and
why one of the reasons we're eager to
have it passed we don't feel that
sending unaccompanied minors kids back
to take a dangerous journey
is the right step to take and that's not
something that we're going to do in his
administration and it won't be our
policy
but we always need to keep communicating
more effectively about how this is a
dangerous time to travel
this is a dangerous time uh for families
to come for children to come
and we'll continue to work to do that
more and when the
president had half a dozen republican
lawmakers in the oval office yesterday
they came out
they shared they thought it was a good
meeting but they said the culver 19
rescue package never came up why not
well did they raise the coven 19 rescue
package
the president says that he makes it a
top priority
he just talks about it with great
urgency
uh he could have brought it up and i'm
just curious well the meeting was about
a supply chain executive order something
that there is a great deal of interest
on and bipartisan support for
the only time the president talks about
the american rescue plan is not in
meetings in the oval office
he picks up his phone and calls
democrats republicans and others on a
regular basis
and i think he's used every opportunity
he has
uh to make the case publicly uh to have
those conversations and
it's probably why more than 70 percent
of the public including more the
majority of republicans support the plan
so that is not a signal that the
president has conceded he is just going
to pass
the package with democrats hardly look i
think
the president's view is that this is a
package
that will help get the pandemic under
control it will help put people back to
work
if somebody has a better idea by all
means bring it forward
we have not seen one this is a plan that
he remains committed to and he is
hopeful
that republicans many in congress will
follow what their constituents want and
the american people
clearly want this rescue plan passed
they clearly want money for vaccinations
they clearly want schools to reopen and
funding to reopen schools and they
clearly want direct checks
so hopefully members will listen to that
and we have plenty of time for
republicans to
vote for the package thank you everyone
thank you
you